quinze cornes dirigeants patrons parti
communiste peut dire ça arnaud était
marxiste orthodoxe d'une certaine
manière parce que quand vous lisez marx
ô marx dit que le travail est
constitutif de l'homme donc de ce point
de vue là il n'y a aucune contradiction
entre les convictions qui doivent être
les convictions de monsieur roussel est
ce qui vient de dire mais la réalité
c'est que c'est vrai qu'il est quand
même un pavé dans la mare on a vu déjà
monsieur roussel se distinguer d'une
partie de la nuit ps notamment de
monsieur mélenchon sur la question de la
laïcité ensuite sur la question du
nucléaire
là il se distingue sur la question du
travail et même il va beaucoup plus loin
que certains sociaux démocrates
auraient pu exprimer aussi d'une
certaine manière parfois des doutes
quant au système social est en tout cas
l'efficacité du système social donc en
effet c'est quelque part une ligne de
divergences fortes qui pose à
l'intérieur de cette coalition de gauche
c'est pas nouveau encore une fois et ça
ne manquera pas encore de faire des
remous avantage conséquent sur la nuque
sur ce que dit un fabien roussel s il
peut dire ça est ce que l'autre partie
de la gauche a raison de dire que c'est
un vocabulaire de droite non je pense
pas je pense que c'est lui qui est dans
l'orthodoxie de la gauche il est dans
l'orthodoxie de la gauche puisque la
gauche aussi bien les écologistes
d'ailleurs que les trotskistes version
mélenchon se sont déportés justement de
la valeur travail qui était tout le
travail qui était vraiment au coeur je
dirais des préoccupations des débats des
on va dire des gens modestes et puis
d'aider des travailleurs précisément et
mélenchon comme les écologistes ont
déporté le sujet et la gauche vers
d'autres préoccupations qui sont cercle
écologie qui n'existait pas au 19e
siècle ni au début du 20e siècle mais
les minorités la défense des minorités
la défense des minorités
principalement et c'est comme ça que
finalement roussel ramène la gauche
d'une certaine façon eh bien ces valeurs
qui sont ces valeurs cardinales du
siècle dernier
et on entend ya une vraie il ya une
vraie divergence justement sur cette
vision du travail on l'a entendu il ya
quelques minutes avec l'interview de
david cormand à l'écologiste pour lui le
travail n'est pas forcément émancipant
il faut travailler moins partagé le
travail il faut avoir le droit à l'oise
yves tu es donc effectivement c'est plus
du tout la même vision que celle de
fabien sait pas bien où ça il a été
marqué par sa campagne dans le nord
campagne difficile auprès des classes
populaires la gauche aujourd'hui elle a
perdu sept places pour les a perdues a
fait les a perdus depuis longtemps que
c'est françois mitterrand disait en 1981
quand il est élu s'il est élu c'est
parce qu'il a le soutien des classes
populaires et on a vu à partir des
années 80 est d'ailleurs déjà sous
françois mitterrand une partie des
classes populaires le plus voté le plus
voté à gauche rappelle qu'un que le
premier le vote ouvrier aujourd'hui la
le parti qui est majoritaire dans le
vautour y est c'est le rassemblement
national donc en effet des fabien
roussel y tire les enseignements de ce
qu'il a entendu sur le terrain dans sa
circonscription de saint-amand-les-eaux
justement dans les hauts de france dont
votre interlocutrice précédente parler
il a entendu en effet des classes des
gens issus des classes populaires qui
travaillent qui considère que
vraisemblablement leur travail ne leur
rapporte pas assez et qui vont à côté en
effet parfois des populations qui elles
finalement on ne travaillons pas dispose
d'un niveau de vie similaire voire
parfois supérieurs aux leurs du fait
qu'il dispose d'un filet social donc
c'est ce qu'il a voulu exprimer et c'est
vrai que la gauche aujourd'hui doit
s'interroger sur les raisons pour
lesquelles elle a perdu le vote des
classes populaires donc ils essayent de
ramener le débat sur une sociologique et
une sociologie historique à gauche parce
que tout simplement il se rend compte
que le rassemblement national qui était
très présent dans sa circonscription
aujourd'hui a réussi à capter
l'électorat populaire et ce discours
peut faire que
l'ouvrier que les classes populaires
reviennent vers la gauche et n'aillent
plus vers leurs assureurs
parce que bon il est quand même pas
majoritaires
agouazi loin de là il a toujours eu un
discours assez
intérêt marginal par rapport aux
ce qu'on écoute ce qu'on entend à gauche
ou sous les discours sur sur la façon de
s'alimenter sûr il ya beaucoup de choses
il est assez traditionnel finalement
d'une gauche on dira qui ressemble plus
à celle de jacques duclos qu'évidemment
à celle de ses deux cécile duflot a
cessé ça paraît assez évident mais parce
qu'il a compris ça il a compris qu
effectivement le populaire il échappe à
la gauche en grande partie si vous
n'avez pas le vote populaire vous ne
pouvez pas être élu président de la
république c'est évident c'est ce qu'a
compris marine le pen d'une certaine
façon parce que effectivement mitterrand
il avait réussi à capter le vote
populaire
nicolas sarkozy en 2007 pourquoi le
rassemblement national est assez je
dirais tu as 10 % à ce moment là mais
parce qu'il a il a réussi à capter le
vote populaire et après la droite et
bien été désertée par
justement cet électorat populaire tout
comme elle déserte le parti socialiste
est déserte le parti communiste déserte
grande partie je dirais des partis
traditionnels donc faut pas oublier
quand même que les abstentionnistes
c'est le premier parti de france et ce
parti-là effet de gens plutôt assez
modeste mais c'est aussi une volonté
chez fabien roussel de se démarquer de
la num justement il est peut-être plus
précisément encore de la france à son
aise oui vraisemblablement si vous
voulez la nuque aujourd'hui là où jean
luc mélenchon a réussi ce qu'il a
restaurée l'idée qu'il y avait une
efficacité électorale à gauche en
ramenant
je ne sais plus enfin près de 180
parlementaires de gauche à l'assemblée
nationale mais c'est vraiment là à voir
qui cache la forêt cette efficience
électorale relative au demeurant parce
qu'on sait très bien qu'il ya
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
divergences entre les différentes
formations politiques pas seulement
entre le parti communiste et la france
soient soumises mais également entre les
écologistes et la france insoumise on
l'a vu encore récemment sur la question
de la relation à la chine où la relation
à la russie il y a des divergences entre
les socialistes et la france est soumise
donc on sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui
cette alliance est une alliance qui
tient quand même sur un fil qui est le
fils de la survie politique mais est ce
qu'on peut construire uniquement sur la
survie politique ça c'est une vraie
question est manifestement monsieur
roussel irait tout à sa façon et en tout
cas dans la stratégie personnelle de
fabien roussel il ya toujours une
opposition à jean luc mélenchon il s'est
fait élire à la tête du parti communiste
justement avec cette idée de séparation
du front de gauche de l'alliance avec
jean luc mélenchon de faire et bien
sonné à la voix singulière du parti
communiste de retrouver un candidat à la
présidentielle il a même maintenu sa
candidature à la présidentielle il a
fait plus de 2% et jean luc mélenchon
lui a reproché selon lui il l'a empêché
d'aller au second tour de la
présidentielle
l'a redit à la fête de l'humanité et
même dès la naissance de cette alliance
de la nuque et bien on a vu fabien
roussel tout de suite prendre ses
distances avec le fameux épisode de la
photo de famille où fabien roussel avait
mariage ou piscine donc c'est une
stratégie personnelle de fabien en selle
depuis des années voilà de se distinguer
et de s'opposer à jean luc mélenchon
mais c'est aussi parce que les
communistes et des trotskistes sont pas
c'est pas les mêmes les trotskistes
son retour était détesté par les
communistes et les communistes et le
parti de l'ordre et les trotskistes
c'est un autre c'est une autre affaire
c'est le parti de l'entrisme c'est le
parti effectivement dès des causes
minoritaires
aujourd'hui en tous les cas et
donc il ya pas de terrain commun oui
mais il ya quelque chose d'assez
intéressant dans l'opposition demande de
jean luc mélenchon qui de ce point de
vue là est assez proche du
positionnement qui fut celui du ps à la
fin des années 2000 et au début des
années 2000 istres je rappelle cette
phase cette fameuse note de terra nova
qui disait finalement aujourd'hui
l'important c'est de s'adresser
justement comme le dit yves aux
minorités c'est ce que fait d'une
certaine manière aujourd'hui jean luc
mélenchon luc mélenchon qui sait quoi
son électorat c'est l agrégat de c'est
un agrégat de minorités d'ailleurs des
unis en l'occurrence mais enfin qui lui
permet d'avoir une forme d'efficacité
électoraux et de ce point de vue là il
est assez proche du logiciel politique
qui fut celui du ps à la fin des années
2000 et au début des années 2010 et sur
la
section socialiste à la nuque peut tenir
du coup on va voir moi je pense qu'elle
peut te dire parce qu'ils n'ont pas
intérêt à ce que ça explose bon sur un
malentendu fin de cette facilité sur un
malentendu ça peut ça peut exploser un
de ces quatre c'était évident mais on va
voir on va voir d'une certaine façon la
c c'est quand même un débat de fond qui
les divisent là aujourd'hui alors aller
du côté de l'autre côté de l'échiquier
politique puisque eric zemmour faisait
sa rentrée politique ce week-end il
était dans le var où il a prononcé un
discours et après le grand remplacement
et le cran déclassement il a alerté hier
sur le grand endoctrinement
au combat il est d'abord culturel il est
d'abord de deux de combattre ce que j'ai
appelé laurent endoctrinement et puis à
moyen terme les prochaines élections les
européennes les municipales etc bah
c'est un peu nouveau dans la bouche
d'eric zemmour papa la théorie mais
cette expression c'est vrai pendant la
campagne présidentielle on a beaucoup
entendu parler du grand des classements
on a beaucoup entendu parler du grand
déplacement hier dans son discours il a
beaucoup parlé de ce grand temps de
traitement ouf c'est la même chose les
racines sont les mêmes 1
grand temps de traitement on voit très
bien quoi il fait référence c'est la
france ça france qui perd ses repères
qui perd sa culture qui cède et bien d
intimidation extérieur
en cela il n'a pas changé de discours du
tout du tout du tout ce qui est assez
intéressant mais ils n'en parlent pas
justement parce que je ne parle pas
tellement de sa stratégie électorale
qu'est ce qui va faire parce que ils
n'ont pas de député il n'ont pas d'élus
lui même est quand même un électron
complètement libre il a il n'a pas de
mandat et ce qui est intéressant c'est
de savoir quel est l'avenir de ceux de
ceux de ce mouvement
il peut y avoir un mois je pense que les
élections européennes précisément qui
est le prochain scrutin que la france va
connaître et bien est un scrutin
complètement fait pour l'eczéma ou parce
qu'on connaît son positionnement on sait
son son discours anti-européen tels que
l'europe existe aujourd'hui l'union
européenne existe aujourd'hui et là il a
une carte à jouer c'est évident en plus
c'est quand même un scrutin qui est un
dont le mode de jeu dire c'est une
élection dont le mode de scrutin lui est
favorable donc il peut avoir des députés
pour le coup là il peut il peut obtenir
quelques sièges de députés au parlement
de strasbourg ce qu'est ce qui n'est pas
le moindre des paradoxes d'ailleurs
parce que en étant anti européen et il
siégera y siégeraient strasbourg comme
d'autres
il a encore une place et
je partage totalement c'est à dire qu'en
fait on des faits le scrutin aux
européennes et peut être favorable en
tout cas au propice à eric zemmour je
crois quand même qu'il à la concurrence
du rassemblement national qui est quand
même encore et partis d'opposition et
donc on a autant et partis d'opposition
à une force là aussi qui non négligeable
dans le cadre d'un scrutin aux
européennes non cette question n'aura
peut-être il a des positions plus
tranchées que marine le pen peut-être
oui peut-être oui vraisemblablement il
n'est plus il disons qu'il est plus
explicite et plus clair que marine le
pen mais sur la question économique il
est beaucoup plus libéral que marine le
pen donc là aussi si vous laissez plus
difficile pour lui lui aussi le problème
c'est d'allier conclut enfin je veux
comme la gauche à l'électorat populaire
parce que ce cas ce qu'a réussi marine
le pen en fait lors des élections
présidentielles et encore une fois lors
de ces élections législatives c'est
d'arriver à arrimer 7,7 sociologie là
que eric zemmour n'a pas réussi
finalement à convaincre eric zemmour il
fait finalement des secours qui sont
importants dans des bastions de la
droite j'allais dire classique
identitaire que l'on retrouve notamment
plutôt dans le sud et celle à qui fait
ses meilleures performances eric zemmour
aujourd'hui il a un avantage c'est que
ces 7 % lui permet d'avoir des
financements et de pouvoir faire marcher
une machine une petite entreprise
politique dans un climat qui reste
encore très instable donc ça c'est une
force mais il a quand même une grosse
faiblesse c'est qu'en effet il n'a aucun
élu il n'a pas de maillage territorial
mais à part celui des bonnes volontés de
ses militants mais donc là il a un vrai
défi bon après tout va dépendre de
l'évolution générale de la situation
politique il ya encore quelques
personnalités à ses côtés on a vu hier
ses côtés sur la tribune marion maréchal
guillaume pelletier nicolas bay nicolas
bay
ça a peut lui être humain doit qui sont
pas 6 1
monsieur rivière je crois qu'avec
gilbert collard se passent pas très très
bien et
oui il arrive là bas je dirais il a la
force de la jeunesse puisque les trois
que bon je n'ai cité en plus affichent
une jeunesse ces dynamiques on va voir
s'est passé parce ça suffit pas
ce qui compte c'est surtout la force
militante aussi il faut que comme il n'a
pas d'élus locaux et qu' il faut qu'ils
aient des relais dans la société et ses
relais ils doivent être nombreux je sais
pas combien ils adhérent est d'autant
qu'un espace est occupé par marine le
pen marine le pen kiel à l'autre bout de
la france dans ces terres du pas de
calais faisait également sa rentrée on
va l'écouter
schéma qu'on croit pouvoir mettre en
oeuvre un gadget qui est le conseil
national de la refondation entouré de
quelques-uns de ses copains pour faire
mine de s'intéresser au sujet donc oui
nous allons aborder à l'assemblée
nationale de gré ou de force par
l'intermédiaire des niches
parlementaires l'intégralité des sujets
qui aujourd'hui ont une conséquence
directe sur la vie quotidienne de nos
compatriotes sur leur liberté sur la
souveraineté du pays et aussi sur des
choses qui sont fondamentales au
quotidien c'est à dire les factures
énergétiques
marine le pen qui continue sur la ligne
de la présidentielle en cette rentrée
elle parle beaucoup de pouvoir d'achat
élevé de la question de l'énergie des
factures des français semble que c'est
elle qui est dans le vrai hein
après on peut contester ce qu'elle dit
mais en tous les cas le choix du sujet
et le meilleur des choix puisque c'est
le quel est le problème aujourd'hui des
français c'est effectivement bien
2 le pouvoir d'achat pouvoir acheter de
quoi sourire de quoi se vêtir la rentrée
scolaire payer le loyer et c'est le sait
au centre de la préoccupation des gens
alors que on sait très bien qu'il ya de
l'inflation que quand même les nuages
s'amoncellent à l'horizon sur le plan
économique c'est quand même pas très
brillant que la croissance ne sera pas
au rendez vous tel qu'on l'avait imaginé
donc sur fois là je ne dis pas qu'elle a
des bonnes réponses mais c'est elle qui
qui qui qui vise juste et c'est elle qui
incarne peut-être une réponse en tout
cas la réponse de l'opposition sur ce
sujet pour les français elle a réussi à
incarner sa sur cette question du
pouvoir d'achat oui parce que si vous
voulez d'ailleurs elle en a fait le
thème principal unique de sa campagne
présidentielle quand souvenons nous
l'année dernière à l'automne tout le
monde était concentré sur le discours
d'eric zemmour sur les questions
régaliennes civilisationnel identitaire
elle a d'une certaine manière pratique
et une contre-programmation pour
reprendre une métaphore
audiovisuels sur la question du pouvoir
d'achat et de ce point de vue là elle a
fait la bonne analyse elle a fait le bon
diagnostic
alors après les réponses c'est autre
chose en effet ceci dit elle est quand
même sur une ligne de crête c'est que
quand on regarde la la la quelle le
début de cette de cette législature elle
a quand même voulu montrer que
le rassemblement national était une
opposition qui était une opposition
constructive c'est à dire qu'on a voté
par exemple le pouvoir le paquet pouvoir
d'achat contrairement à la halle à nu
baisse mais il ya aussi de la part d'une
grande partie de son électorat une
demande de radicalité d'opposition donc
il va falloir qu'à un moment donné elle
arrive à tenir les deux bouts c'est à
dire à la fois montrer qu'elle est
responsable mais en même temps qu'elle
n'a rien perdu de sa détermination dans
l'anti ma chronique parce qu'il ya une
demande dont il ma chronique de son dans
son électorat qui est forte allez on a
terminé en allant royaume uni est le
royaume uni est évidemment toujours sous
le coup de l'émotion après le décès de
la reine elizabeth ii et ce week end et
bien ont débuté les cérémonies d'hommage
à la reine et dans le même temps charles
le prince charles est devenu le roi
charles iii regarde ça avec sandra sarca
lentement le corbillard d'elisabeth 2
recouvert de l'étang d'un royal écossais
kit balmoral pour son dernier voyage
hier il est un peu plus de 10 heures
lorsque le cercueil prend la route pour
un parcours de 300 km juste derrière
elle sa fille la princesse anne a pris
place dans une limousine avec son mari
pour suivre le cercueil premiers
villages traversés balle à terre ou la
reine avait ses habitudes
l'émotion était particulièrement intense
certains sont venus en voisins d'autres
ont fait plus de six heures de route
pour rendre un dernier hommage à la
reine défunte
c'était une personne forte elle a
vraiment fait beaucoup de sacrifices
pour elle même et pour le pays et cela
mérite beaucoup de respect règne et je
pense que nous pouvons apprendre
beaucoup d'elle à cet égard c'est toute
une époque qui s'est refermée maintenant
en fin d'après midi c'est à edimbourg
capitale de l'ecosse et résidence
officielle de la couronne que s'achève
le parcours à l'arrivée du cercueil les
consignes de silence sont encore
respectée mais pas pour longtemps
les applaudissements d'abord timides
sont de plus en plus nourris alors que
la reine arrive au palais d'edimbourg
son cercueil est exposé à la cathédrale
saint gilles où le public pourra lui
rendre un dernier hommage les obsèques
auront lieu lundi 19 septembre à la
build au westminster
samedi a marqué le début d'une nouvelle
ère pour la monarchie britannique
le fils de la défunte reine est devenu
charles iii après avoir prêté serment au
palais de saint james
[Musique]
le prince charles philippe artur jorge
après la mort de notre cher souveraine
devient notre seul et légitime roi
charles iii
charles iii sera le roi des années 2020
la cérémonie est retransmise pour la
première fois à la télévision mais le
rituel multiséculaire et respecté à la
lettre
[Musique]
pour le roi
c'est donc sous les ors du palais de st
james que les hauts dignitaires du pays
se sont réunis pour proclamer
solennellement son accession au trône au
vote et dans la salle sont présents et
de nous aux anciens premiers ministres
charles iii 41e monarque depuis
guillaume le conquérant jure de suivre
l'exemple de sa mère celle dont il est
resté si longtemps dans l'une des plaies
au web je suis conscience de ce grand
héritage des devoirs et des lourdes
responsabilités de la couronne
obsidienne de mettre transmis votre
journal
god save the king anton la foule il va
falloir prendre l'habitude dé changer de
repère pour charles iii qui hérite d'un
royaume fragilisé sous les coups du
breakbeat et de la crise économique
les défis sont immenses
voilà et on a vu un samedi notamment
avec une journée historique puisque
c'est la première fois qu'on pourrait
rentrer dans les arcanes de
l'intronisation d'un roi et en même
temps on a vu tout le paradoxe lors de
cette journée arnaud avec à la fois
évidemment l'émotion et les larmes des
britanniques les pleurs et les abel 2 et
que la liesse et les ouvrants
vis-à-vis de charles iii oui mais
j'allais dire le principe de la
monarchie la reine est morte vive le roi
c'est la transmission c'est la force de
la tradition c'est la conservation d'une
très longue histoire qui s'exprime de la
sorte c'est à dire que c'est en effet un
moment de tristesse parce que le corps
du roi est mort mais en même temps le
corps du roi ressuscite tout simplement
parce que il y a cette tradition est cet
enchaînement j'allais dire
institutionnel qui donne une grande
stabilité finalement à ce pays parce que
ce qui ce qui est extraordinaire avec le
royaume uni c'est cette impression de
stabilité malgré une instabilité
politique de ces dernières années on a
changé beaucoup de premiers ministres
ces dernières années au royaume uni et
en même temps on a ce sentiment de
stabilité ce qui explique vincent qu'en
france il ya eu beaucoup de commentaires
pays vieux view pays république et enfin
d'ailleurs plutôt vieux pays monarchique
devenu républicain et on sent qu'il ya
comme une espèce de nostalgie par
rapport en tout cas une sorte de
fascination par rapport à ce qui se
passe du côté
par rapport à ce qui se passe outre
manche où ouais effectivement pour
parler de l'ambivalence on a vu alors sa
petite polémique 1 ce week-end puisque
emmanuel macron a demandé aux maires de
mettre les drapeaux en berne le jour le
lendemain de la mort et alors il ya
quelques maires qui refuse de mettre ses
drapeaux en berne vous vous comprenez ça
y est on sait que c'est je pense que
c'est c'est pas un autre honneur d'une
certaine façon parce que c'est bon mais
c'est vrai qu'on est en deux régimes
différents même si on est dans une
monarchie républicaine enfin bon c'est
moi c'est ça paraît assez évident moi ce
qui est ce que je trouve extraordinaire
les images que vous venez de montrer et
puis dans le récit de cette
à la fois de ceux de cette disparition
et de cette renaissance immédiate
c'est que la grande bretagne a très bien
en ce moment allait quand même
frappé par une crise économique
peut-être encore supérieure à la nôtre
parce que justement elle a quitté
l'europe pour plein de raisons et
hébron est la seule quand même se
permettre si vous me permettez
l'expression
dix jours de deuil là c'est à dire que
le pays est à l'arrêt complet quoi
suspendu j'entendais quelqu'un un
économiste qui disait que ça allait leur
coûter quelques décimales de
de produit intérieur brut - est-ce
qu'ils peuvent se le permettre j'en sais
rien mais bon il ya ça et puis
effectivement il ya ce que disait arnaud
c'est à dire là mais cette espèce de
fascination qui est des qui est exercée
sur le reste du monde keke là qui
regarde ça avec
beaucoup de 2,2 de passion d'une
certaine façon y compris d'ailleurs dans
les anciens pays du commonwealth alors
les pays du commonwealth qui sont des
anciennes colonies je pense notamment
d'afrique au kenya ou là
la décolonisation au kenya a été très
violente et pourtant la reine garde
garde une aura et ben dans ces pays-là
lundi prochain
ce sera le jour des obsèques à des
funérailles d'elizabeth ii on suivra
bien évidemment tout ça
[Musique]